what is like the so the best way just
legally streaming
paying for the services is that the best
way uh in your opinion
i've heard that the dvds blu-ray dvds
for example
i'm not sure about the us but in japan
buying the blu-ray dvds is the best
yeah yeah yeah that's when they know
yeah because they they measure success
from blu-ray sales right that's
when we have that and like the original
uh sources
sale yeah like the manga oh so the [ __ ]
and stuff like that okay that's what
i've heard
because i always try to make sure i buy
my manga first hand now like even if
it's like an
older series where i could easily go to
like a book off or something and buy it
for 100 yen like i always just try and
go to the bookstore
the firsthand bookstore because like
i've heard that is truly the best way to
support the creator
right i guess because when it's
pre-owned right like like royalties
don't go
yeah right i mean like two-thirds of my
jojo merch is like pre-owned stuff
that's because it's like
you can't get that stuff because for
some reason it wasn't made for you it
wasn't available at the time
like yeah i don't know like spent
thousands of dollars on like yahoo
auction right but none of that goes to
like
because a lot of the time as well like
this merch is like what like a hundred
bucks and then two years later on yahoo
auction it's 300 bucks
and someone made a nice profit i mean
good for that iraqis definitely not
seeing that profit right yeah
i mean you know the only thing that i've
bought that's like brand new
is probably the jump store stuff that we
both bought
like because uh the jojo exhibition
museum was cancelled
and normally you have to go to the jojo
exhibition to get the stuff but they
were like hey you can just order it
online so i ordered like
suits the suits as well i got that but
the thing is
with the suits right that's bandai
collaboration with perfect suit factory
oh yeah so there's like two companies
that are making this thing before yeah
they're taking most of it
so like these 500 suits how many of that
goes to like
you know shonen jump and then are like
like the animators aren't seeing that
[ __ ] right the animators are still
underpaid as [ __ ]
i mean i don't think there's anything we
can do for paid because it's just
japan's salary the average salary in
general
man mike is taking a beating yeah like
in general is low
yeah yeah i mean i i feel like with
animators it's a
like systematic problem with how the
industry works as a whole
that's a whole other camera that's
that's a whole other kind of word that's
also just like
japanese culture yeah yeah that's that's
that's a whole different argument
to be had but um i think one thing i see
with a lot of like western twitter and
western people is that i feel like they
don't
want to support the industry mostly
because they're not happy with like some
of these
bigger companies or like the image of
like say crunchyroll or funimation
and it's it's it's less of i don't want
to support the industry and more of
i don't want to support these companies
in particular
yeah do you want you don't want to
support the companies that are
representing the industry in my country
right
i can understand it at times because you
know there's a lot of arguments that
people make like underpinnings
underpinning translators that comes up a
lot and you know you know like last year
like it was like voice actor apocalypse
funimation like there's a lot of reasons
why people might not want to right and
it's
it's tough because it's it's because i
don't think there's a
right or wrong argument but
what what i feel sometimes that a lot of
people will won't support the industry
unless like
a perfect system where all the money
they go to goes to this one creator like
they want to
they want a utopian system like like
like a utopian system where like every
creator has a [ __ ] patreon or
something and they can support
any creator they want and how much they
want and that's just not a business
model you know what i mean yeah and i
feel like a lot of people
use that justification to say hey we're
not supporting the creator how i want to
support the creator
um so i'm just not going to support
anything and i feel like there must be
there must be a better way to go about
it than that because there's never going
to be a person
trigger kind of did the right thing
right like they have a patreon they have
a twitch stream where they do like
patreon
i'm not too sure i think i checked and i
was like i was like that is nowhere near
enough to
oh no definitely not it's basically just
like a side revenue for them
but at least it's a way that is will
actually go
directly to the studio and is a payment
method or a donation method that
westerners are very familiar with right
so
i think it's good to have just an option
to do something like that it's like hey
do you want to directly support the
studio and like you know
has that it's not a studio but like
there are some illustrators oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely but i mean
like yeah i mean
that's really the only thing and
barely anybody's utilizing it right like
i've never heard of a manga artist
using patreon is it like joking there's
like a pride thing
in japan like not wanting to ask people
for money because like begging is really
like
not a thing here i don't know i mean
culturally you're being smarter
yeah like not even homeless people yeah
you don't see yeah homeless people like
just do their own thing yeah like that's
just like all right
[ __ ] you you've never seen him yeah yeah
because it's not a
disrespectful yeah it's not a thing here
like there's so even the homeless here
are respectful where they're just like
no no no no
keep your money yeah they're like i'm
i'm i'm i'm homeless i still have my
prize
yeah yeah exactly it's i think it's just
a different culture
there's a lot of it that comes down to
that though i think in the industry and
how people want it to change it's just
not going to i also i also think a
really big
root of the problem when it comes to at
least the anime industry is that they
truly
even though in my experience having you
know done stuff with a lot of different
studios and
productions and whatnot in anime they're
aware of the western industry
they just don't really give a [ __ ] about
them yeah like it's people say they care
they don't know how it's not their first
priority though their first priority is
always
the japanese market right and that's and
that's how they measure their success i
mean of course you know
i'm sure all of these studios now it's
2020 right like i think most of them are
aware now that there are way more
western fans
who are into their anime than there will
ever be japanese fans right
but china alone right yeah or just
south east asia even all the mobile
games coming out for china yeah
even if you just look at southeast asia
right that's more people just in general
who will watch the anime and enjoy the
anime and be willing to spend the money
on it but
because the japanese anime industry is
so a lot of it is so
old-fashioned and you know thinking just
locally
that they're just like okay we
understand that there are all these
people out here who are probably willing
to pay for our stuff
yeah we just don't know how to do it but
we can't be bothered to figure out how
to i mean
it's culture in general though isn't it
yes it's just like for example the dvd
and blu-ray
business model is just not going to work
abroad
yeah you know what i mean i mean it can
prop up the anime industry here in japan
and it has for like the longest time
but it took them like how many years to
figure out that people just don't want
to buy dvd
that's like if crunchyroll was like
we're going to open up a blockbuster
tomorrow come on in and
rent your dvds like no it's not
you know it's yeah like it's it's
shocking how many people
in japan do not know streaming services
yeah like even young people
i just are not aware they're like oh you
can you can watch anime on netflix what
they usually record it on their tv like
when it's
yeah when it's playing on tv yeah but
it's like i'm not staying up till 3am to
watch a [ __ ] rent a girlfriend
i've never seen a place where they like
sell uh crt tv
so much like their crt i mean
smash players were like yes yes like
everyone else is like why the [ __ ] would
i need to see our tv
yeah there's so many those big [ __ ]
chunky ones
tvs like i see so many of them it's the
tv that you grew up with like the giant
like the [ __ ] brick of a t
the thick boys i was in uh akihabara and
it was like a brand new electronics
store there was like lcd
like thin tvs and there's a whole
section for crt
tvs and i'm like who the [ __ ] is buying
this
genuinely who the [ __ ] is buying crt tv
because like
for smash play except like